you are one of uh very few independent
thinkers on the internet at this point
uh
there's uh kind of this pursuit of
consensus over truth which
yes as you and i probably agree on is is
pretty stupid
um help me understand kind of the view
of the world from somebody living
outside the united states right now
given the pandemic that's going on and
kind of the economic crisis
um what's generally the view of the
united states from
overseas or kind of other people that
you talk to
over in europe i think the consensus is
i think i think the narrative i think
the narrative
is that um some countries including the
usa i think there's
the narrative is that they haven't
handled this
very well and you get that from
different angles right you have the
you have the people who are you know
think there should have been more
lockdowns and things should have been
you know people should have just grabbed
the reins of control and forced people
to wear masks and forced lockdowns and
instituted fines and stuff and then you
have the people who are you know
more libertarian-minded who are like the
lockdown was a disaster destroyed the
economy unnecessarily
for virus with a 99.9 survival rate
it didn't make sense to do this to make
all these people unemployed etc
and um you know there's i can understand
both of those perspectives
and but i think what we're witnessing
this year is just a lot of
i think we're seeing sort of every
every interesting phenomenon in human
psychology taking place
right cognitive dissonance mob mentality
confirmation bias um like every
you know the politicization of things
that shouldn't be politicized
people forming teams tribalism etc
we've seen all of this play out so much
over the past few months
and i think that
there are there are some things that are
really really obvious when it comes to
the whole pandemic situation and the
response to it that no one
wants to even be honest about and i can
understand why certain people don't want
to be honest about
i think one of those things is that
nobody
nobody had a freaking clue right no no
one wants to just admit that like okay
like
you know in just in january in january
they were saying there's no human human
transmission
right they said masks don't work don't
wear masks don't buy masks and then they
said
absolutely wear a mask if you don't wear
a mask you're going to kill my grandma
they said that you can't go out and
protest you remember they had the
lockdown protests and people were
clamping down on them
a couple weeks later you've got
thousands out in the streets black lives
matters protests and you even have to
have health experts
saying that it's okay because racism is
a bigger virus
and the the goal post they said flat in
the curve
and then we flatten the curve right just
a couple weeks to slow the spread that's
how they
got everybody to comply that was months
ago now but the gyms are still closed
the churches are still closed etc they
just keep moving the goal posts and
no one wants to admit okay we didn't
know what was going on
and no one wants to admit okay perhaps
we overreacted
and you know this wasn't as bad as we
thought it would be at the beginning
they were saying the death rate could be
three percent to five percent
now it turns out that if you are
under the age of about 50 and you don't
have
big underlying conditions your chance of
survival is virtually 100
percent right you can look at the
figures you can see who this is
impacting if you're over the age of
you know 70 or so 65 70
yeah absolutely you want to be careful
you want to take more precautions
it would make sense to perhaps self
quarantine yourself you know take
additional measures
but no one wants to just admit any of
this stuff so people are still
pretending
that you know children are just as at
risk as
80 year olds which is not true they're
trying to pretend that people like
yourself and myself are just
as at risk and need to take the same
precautions as people in nursing homes
which we know is not true
we know so many things but no one
because so many mistakes have been made
and everyone's trying to
score political points and do this and
do that i mean even when it comes to the
medical advice even when it comes to the
so-called experts how many times have
the experts been wrong
right there are no experts because it
takes time to become an expert it takes
years there's no coronavirus experts
not for coven 19 because it's new and it
takes time to become an expert so
whatever is said needs to be taken with
a massive grain of salt and
there are just so many people just have
different dogs in the fights and no one
wants to be honest and everyone is lying
from the media to the politicians to
this to that there's too many
there's too many um conflicting
opinions and views and everyone wants to
win
and that's the that's kind of the
problem and so
like i don't talk about the pandemic a
lot because it just gets people people
just get so
freaked out and amped up and i mean you
were asking before the call like what
the situation is like where i live and i
was saying that the
you know the amount of cases and stuff
throughout this whole thing has been
um you know been very low and it's not
an i don't live in an area that's been
heavily impacted i live by myself
i don't like ice i've been socially
distancing
for a while regardless for the most part
and then like i had one day where
i tweeted something about the fact that
i don't wear a mask
and i got like people you would have
thought that i like admitted to like
being a serial killer or something the
way people responded
and it's crazy because people don't even
factor in the fact that like things are
different in different parts of the
world and in different places so
someone might be in a place that's
heavily affected and everyone's wearing
masks and what i'm like
no one wears a mask here like it's not
it's not i think like i can go outside i
can go to the part park there's
thousands of people are out people no
people aren't even social distancing
those
it's like well it's not a heavily
affected area so the precautions here
are not going to be the same as in new
york city
or even in london etc but the mask
itself has even become like a tribal
symbol it's become a political to become
politicized now it's
you know if you don't wear a mask you're
a bad person and you know we must force
these people
the whole thing's just it's just become
farcical at this point you know i think
it's
i've just kind of removed myself from
the conversation and it's just like
look i'm just gonna use common sense
like i've been doing the whole time i'm
gonna go about my business look after my
health
not try to put other people
unnecessarily at risk
um which i haven't been doing regardless
of what people want to say